[Music]
kicks was at the very beginning of the
game probably top five most well-known
most popular most watched people
he was the first one to really have like
great movement and great mechanical
skills out of anyone that i personally
saw retiring from a pro to be a caster
because the casters we had weren't that
great at the time trying to fix it from
the inside out he only needs two more
and they're both still very low he can
deny the plant with the evil eye and
just keep himself alive 19 bullets so
he's got to be careful with that
ammunition counter and here's the denial
[Applause]
seconds and cameraman has to rush will
he land the shots
incredible
he lended legitimacy to rainbow six
because this is the first professional
player that gets to talk about it
there's so much influence that he had he
was so passionate it's because he had so
much
undying love for the game and what it
brought the plant going down bio has to
cover and he's gonna do a great job of
it but no jarvis drops from ceo bio
still has time to win the fights but why
are you sprinting bio pretty much
single-handedly save siege you know
[Applause]
the rainbow six community and the
esports world as a whole lost a great
with the passing of michael kickstar
stockley
you know kicks we lost obviously a you
know community member
like a pro league caster like the void
will never be filled
i mean i don't know what rainbow six
esports looks like right now without
kicks i don't
it's really hard to put into words
exactly you know what what we lost when
kicks passed away but um yeah we lost
someone really special
[Music]
michael kickstar stockley had been
around since the very beginning of
rainbow six siege and i mean
the very beginning what made me get into
rainbow six uh it was an fps game that
had just come out well it hadn't come
out it was in beta i liked playing fps
games and i saw the game and i was like
i'm going to play that an fps obsessed
18 year old kix hadn't just spent
virtually every second of his
adolescence immersing himself in
shooters
he obsessed over them i think i started
playing fps games when i was like
9 or 10 years old you really need to
invest time and keep going at it to
actually become good at video games
unfortunately kicks was the product of a
truly tumultuous childhood for him
gaming was less of a pastime and more of
an escape my mom met some douchebag some
prick
this guy
was he was an [ __ ] oh my god he was
an [ __ ] he was verbal he was it was
verbally abusive towards me my sister
and my mom and he made our lives hell
but he introduced me to pc gaming
he showed me what pc gaming was so too
was content creation from fear to
project blackout to cs go to the
free-to-play fun house where he invested
the vast majority of his efforts warface
kix was your classic cracked youtuber
who would stop at nothing to make a name
for himself so i got kind of
pushed out of my house by things that
happened and right now i'm
crashing on someone's couch just
chilling i'm sorry that i haven't
uploaded and i tried to put out two
videos today two mix videos just uh as a
sorry you know apology for not uploading
for a whole month i hope you guys enjoy
them but it wasn't until the end of 2015
when ubisoft's messy yet revolutionary
tom clancy-themed tax shooter entered
beta that you could truly say kix found
his calling any pro player will tell you
the same story um
really with this sort of thing it's like
you you kind of just pick up on the
intrinsic value
of siege when you first play it you can
just kind of feel
but this is this is that game
and
um i just had that same kind of thing as
everybody else you were like you were
nasty at the start of the game i
remember because i remember playing i
remember watching and i remember playing
against you and like it was noticeable
because most people couldn't shoot and
you could actually shoot
over the course of 2016 kickstar began
to cement himself as one of the nuttiest
most foundational fraggers in north
america i think he was one of the first
people to have like actually really good
mechanical skills in the game like you
know for for me and a lot of other
people in this game it's you know you
get a decent name and stuff like that
but you can get by a lot on like like
you know just using your brain using
strategy using the gadgets in the game
but kicks had like the whole package
he was really smart he had awesome like
usage of gadgets and stuff like that and
just his he was the first one to really
have like great movement and great
mechanical skills out of anyone that i
personally saw for a community that was
just coming into its own kicks wasn't
just a figurehead he was a trailblazer a
teacher someone from whom players knew
and experienced alike could learn the
ins and outs of siege a lot of the
things that people
now do today right like getting getting
valkyrie cameras in like prime positions
and running out of them i mean a lot of
that was like kicks and the other people
did do it too but that was like like a
lot of the the early strats of like like
that were like pioneer in the game like
the aggressive ash plays like those were
that was a lot of that was him like he
really was like one of the first people
doing like that kicks was
at the very beginning of the game
probably top five most well-known most
popular most watched people at that
exact moment there was no bolo king
george wasn't king george at the time
you were in north america you watched
kicks that's it you watched kicks you
wanted kicks to succeed by march he'd
made his way onto orbit and was
competing in the inaugural season of esl
pro league where his roster secured the
first overall seed in north america and
a top four finish internationally and by
season two they managed to claw their
way all the way to the finals
unfortunately after falling short in
that final and watching as his roster
sort of fell apart kix found himself in
a bit of a tough spot despite flirting
with retirement kicks played out half a
season with orbit's spin-off orgless
before calling it quits for real and
then he was presented with a new
opportunity one that changed everything
i retired in the middle of the third
season
not being comfortable on the team that i
was playing with at the time
and
one of my good friends panky he jumped
on one of my streams and in the chat
he's just like hey you want to
commentate
i was like yeah let's do that now i just
want to see what happens on hereford
because hereford could be anyone's map i
between these two teams like you said we
haven't seen a whole lot of hereford i
have no idea like this is
this is gonna be this is who knows maybe
uh maybe flipside can bring it back
bring it to a tied game that'd be pretty
pretty awesome he lended legitimacy to
rainbow six because this is the first
professional player that gets to talk
about it and having somebody to come in
and explain to you
here's why this action is happening and
a probe team is acting in a certain way
made a lot of a lot of things click in
people's heads because they're like
well now i understand what it's about
this is when everybody will scream
obviously here we're looking at a
construction open now that that makes me
think that what's gonna happen next is
he's gonna go ahead and open the stock
drop because there's not a whole lot of
reason to open the moto drop and the
construction drop although i've seen
some teams do it i'm i'm curious to see
how they handle this attack honestly i
could always go back and like re-watch
our pro league games and stuff and i was
like okay i agree with every single
thing that kix is saying he actually
understands what's going on he's able to
break down the plays that we have you
know he understands like the strategy
behind what we're doing what the enemy
team is doing mistakes that are made
mistakes that are not made like he's he
was the really the first person to
really
be able to do that and for as a caster
by 2017 he'd been recruited to cast
siege's first ever ubisoft hosted world
championship the invitational let's
welcome the rest of the caster team we
have panky and kickstar
thanks matt hey how's it going it's good
as soon as si came to a close kicks went
all in on casting he relocated to poland
so as to cast pro league from the
comfort of the esl studio and threw
himself mind and body into his craft i
was waking up at
midnight to go in at 1am to cast the
north america pro league until 6 a.m i
cast the north american pro league in
the beginning of the week and the
european problem in the end of the week
unfortunately this meant that he wasn't
always the easiest to work with kix was
a very young caster who in addition to
being away from home and somewhat
anti-social by nature had had a pretty
hard life it wasn't always easy to get
the best out of him he was hard to work
with i mean nobody's gonna deny that not
the greatest reputation here in poland
when he you know moved to katowice to
work on the in the studio yeah he wasn't
super social
he had a hard time making friends and
you could tell the atmosphere in the
studio that he didn't feel super great
there he's reserved she kind of keeps to
himself
and he will randomly go off and do his
own thing uh you're like walking around
having a chat and he sees something off
in the distance and he just
walks someone out to it you know and
checks it out or just starts dancing in
the street singing something nice and
this is this was michael you know he's
all over the place there's so much
happening at the same time in his head
he had this very very hard shell once
you want to manage to break through this
shell and and see his true self
he was a completely different person
lovely
you know full of energy caring person
but also that had to you know he had to
evolve over the years it was also around
this time that kicks started to
transition away from youtube and towards
twitch i didn't stream back then like
like no one really did it was honestly
like pretty much probably like kicks in
serenity at the time there was no one
else streaming really so he was he was
really the first one to be like hey like
there are cool things you could do in
this and i'm going to record it and i'm
going to share it with the world and you
know help help this game grow and help
people understand that there's like
limitless possibilities with everything
you could do in this game with his
content creation skyrocketing almost as
quickly as his casting career little did
kicks no
by the end of that year he'd have made
the most fateful acquaintance of all i
ended up reaching out to him
and we just started talking
it kind of piqued his interest because
he heard that i was a caster and he and
i got along fairly well right off the
hop
and he said can you send me some clips
of you casting so i was like okay sure i
can do that
i didn't know that it was at the time
to potentially replace his caster that
he was working with but that's what it
ended up being for i just thought he was
curious
and he ended up watching it and he said
to me after a couple days of talking
back and forth
i'm going to be totally blunt with you i
uh
i want somebody new to cast with and i
think you're pretty good would you move
to poland to do it
and that's kind of where it all began
hello and welcome to play day number two
of the north american pro pro league my
name is kickstar and i am joined by a
new addition to our roster in terrell
bang how is it going in terra bang how
are you feeling about your first day of
pro league casting i'll be honest and
just say get out of the way it is a
little nerve-wracking but i am extremely
humbled and very appreciative to be
given this opportunity to say that kicks
and entero had chemistry
would be an understatement it wasn't
chemistry it was magic and he'll obscure
that theory he gets a kill on the neck
rocks but nbk is able to get wilkie
first bootsy gets softened up and it's
really just chante who's fighting at
full force here they spray into the
smoke canadian and him spy one another
as down goes canadian he shoots at the
corpse as bootsy eliminates him and now
shantae runs it he's gonna go for the
plank onto the mirror but as nbk picks
up yet another kill it's just shatter
the kappa tower peeps around the corner
he out duels bc but it's still a 1v2 and
they have control of the hatch above
this is going to be different
the attackers do have the hatch or do
have the plan it will go down nvk second
left patrolling above
the diffuser should go down quite easily
but now shantae nbk drop that's one a
huge round from shantae he could clutch
this out it's just young left will we be
able to see
one around from him and hence steals it
away from eg
one of the greatest clutches i have seen
especially at this finals shot day we
talked about he needs to step it up for
them to win this match and he certainly
did kix pretty much has
as much knowledge as you could possibly
have on the game right of all the
operators gadgets pro plate takes
strategy
usage trick like any anything you could
pretty much name off the top of your
head kicks has that and
entero can just talk and talk and talk
and talk
and he's good at it he is okay i'll give
him credit requests too he's good at it
so that combination of
being able to talk forever and and that
having someone actually like give you
things to talk about and get and you
know back up like the knowledge on what
you're talking about that's a great
combo right there you can see psycho
he's got that top west side control and
he's going to continue to try and clear
out these roamers but it's just
continuing to stall cancer kenny the
first kill of this series the second
kill of this year the third kill of this
series takes out giulio and pzd before
he gets a refract from kamikaze what an
amazing roam from cancer ricketti he's
taken almost all of wags help down as
well he's gonna get pushed by kamikaze
is he gonna be able to get out that's a
fourth kill for kanto there's only one
left standing in the way between the
entire team he doesn't have very much
health left but neither does wag and
ents coming off strong or rather kanto
coming off strong
you'll see now though wag will move and
he'll get as far away from the ella of
canto righty as he can no age for you
and he will fall inside of garage but
kixon and taro were more than just a
casting duo they were comrades kindred
spirits
dear dear friends
brothers
everybody that he casted with up until
that point he was never friends with
right it was more like a work
relationship it was they were colleagues
and some of them he just outright didn't
particularly like for a variety of
reasons i i feel could be that next
cinderella story yes where excellence
was a cinderella story last season this
season me has that has that potential
yeah i thought he was a total oddball
but he was entertaining i thought he was
exceptionally smart and we got along
quite well and we had a lot of mutual
interests and i think
when we first started talking before we
even knew we were gonna cast together i
think he was just drawn to having a
friend i think he was in poland he was
isolated he was lonely and i think he
saw in somebody hey this guy's
relatively normal
and i can get along with him and i think
that went a long way i went to vancouver
but i was like
five so i was like two years ago
this is what i live with
this is what we live with
fair enough and after years of
commitment to competition kicks made
commentary his focus at the end of 2018
right as the game was really starting to
explode i don't think kicks ever really
viewed himself as a caster until our
casting scene started to grow
around mid to late 2018. up until that
point casting in rainbow six was you
didn't really get a lot of publicity
rainbow six wasn't really the talk of
the town it was an esport that kinda lay
in obscurity the players were the real
stars not the casters and he had an
opportunity to leave in 2018 that was
presented to him to go join an
up-and-coming org and maybe get back
into the playing component probably not
but at least be back in the action as a
coach or a general manager strategist
analyst whatever role they had for him
and i think he was drawn to that because
he up until that point he saw himself as
a still a pro player who had been kind
of down on his luck you know he had some
bad luck with teams he got booted off he
left teams because he didn't like them
and he always wanted to go back because
he wanted to be the best and as the
casting realm evolved and things started
to get more serious and competition
amongst casters started heating up i
think he realized hey i can actually
move my energy towards this because
there's far greater challenges in front
of me as a commentator than there are as
a player narrow shot on an s but ness
won't miss his and on full hb he's gonna
have full control of projector and
because of that able to take down giulio
psycho whips out the smg pistol but the
nade from sexy will shut him down
kamikaze the last defender but he can't
make it happen what a round from nesca
and one round from liquid to take it
michael when is your wrap-up album
dropping
i don't what are you talking about you
went full rap god on that one this dude
could seamlessly jump from expert
analyst to surgical shoutcaster at the
drop of a hat vanessa's getting shot
from behind c4 comes out but it's too
late 9xt two kills in this round and
he's being a big factor for his team
dark zero down to hot and cold who's
managed to light up the lion and map
only one full hp attacker left but it's
the same story for hot and cold and
there goes cameraman it's one shot for
9xt one shot for mav and hot and cold
will win this out only 26 bullets left
in that alda but that's plenty and he
knows this low hp he could use his evil
eyes to win this there's still 40
seconds left so this is not a rush
situation for faze they will pick up
cameraman the build up to hoten is
perfect because the actual
casting of the the clutch is good
it's great
but what i actually think is better is
how he sets it up
when haunting is on the main stairs and
he has to rotate
through tellers and archives
into small office
that is he paints the scene beautifully
he sets expectations he states win
conditions while talking about player
positioning denoting the time giving a
sense of urgency giving how dire the
situation is for both teams and what's
on the line and then immediately pivots
to play-by-play
effortlessly and gives it the energy it
deserves he is his own color and
play-by-play for the final 30 seconds so
we're back to a one-on-three the tension
is huge
well evil eye going to be a massive
factor here for hot and cold if he can
play this correctly he cannot vault this
so he'll prep it but that'll give away
his rotation and his intentions it
doesn't seem that 9xt has noticed this
though it doesn't seem like there's a
camera and there's a nice kill for hot
and gold and he passes off to himself
in just like stunning fashion he doesn't
miss anything there's nothing missed
i don't know how you put that
you you go to a lab and create the best
casting possible for that scenario and i
don't know how the result that we have
now is improved upon he only needs two
more and they're both still very low he
can deny the plant with the evil eye and
just keep himself alive 19 bullets so
he's got to be careful with that
ammunition counter and here's the denial
oh my
[Applause]
incredible
but it wasn't just kicks and ontario's
elegant interplay that fans adored
it was their hilarity i saw him i saw
him deploy after he don't make that sick
goal with your hand don't i saw him
deploy that gesture ever again he did he
did the shield thing
stop why what is wrong with your brain
you could tell that they had this
amazing chemistry they just they just
know exactly what the other person wants
to say
they knew their sense of humor
and
no
you could tell on camera that they are
friends by the time 2020 rolled around
siege was undergoing a much deserved
blow up and with excitement around the
game reaching a fever pitch kicks and
ontario cemented themselves as one of
esports's most in-demand duos
psycho's gonna have to clutch up hard
gets the second to die
only 20 seconds left for that plant it's
a stick from rafael so a one-on-one
effectively here psycho wins it and now
another one on one as raphael's at the
post play there it is
4k and ninjas and pajamas the 7-4
taking the map and the series europe's
gone let him forward unfortunately the
toll that kovid took on siege was
significant with everything moving
online kix was afforded the chance to
relocate back home and spend some
much-needed quality time not just with
his family but with himself and then he
started caring about his appearance and
he started getting tailored suits and he
started you know getting imported
jackets and he started looking at
watches and he started wearing rings and
all of a sudden he's caring about his
appearance he's caring about things
outside of gaming and his whole world
opened up to him over the next year and
a half kicks grew as both a caster and
creator expanding his horizons like
never before nothing excited kicks like
world class siege and nothing tilted him
like subpar siege his praise was coveted
and his criticisms carried weight he's
like the hassanabe of
rainbow six he's always getting away
with it the plant going down bio has to
cover and he's going to do a great job
of it but no jarvis drops from ceo bio
still has time to win the fights but why
are you sprinting bio he actually like
understood the game he understood like
the strategy at a fundamental level and
he understood that people are making
mistakes so like yeah he has like the
like like like license to say it i guess
but it's for good reason like it's not
just like he's just saying it to say it
just to criticize he doesn't like
someone or something it's it's just true
first right [ __ ] there right there
that's where he [ __ ] up you see it he
got down
you see that he
up first
problem with with stand since it's only
on this operator is that it gave him
another opportunity it gave him a buffer
of like you can pick up one time but
these guys can't pick up one time you
can not them and he had
that credibility that came from being a
player that he could call out teams and
he could call out bad plays
where none of the other casters could do
that and that brought
this
this weight to the broadcast this
legitimacy to the broadcast because he
was a former pro the siege community
revered and respected kickstar like no
other he'd stood side by side with the
game on every step of its journey and
had played a pivotal role in helping it
to blossom into a globally successful
esport it's not an overstatement to say
that without kicks siege would not be
what it is today what he did for the
scene was insane
uh you know he is one of the he's pretty
much single-handedly saved siege you
know retiring from a pro to be a caster
because the casters we had weren't that
great at the time trying to fix it from
the inside out you know he sacrificed a
lot of his own dreams so that he could i
guess build a better future for the game
that he fell in love with kix was
finally reaping in the benefits of his
years of hard work and sacrifice he'd
helped siege become the esport it
promised to be all while inspiring
countless players content creators and
casters alike but in the fall of 2021 as
he signed off his stream to go for a
customary late night drive
he did so not knowing it would be for
the last time
thank you for watching everybody it was
a
pretty pretty uh pretty stream today but
i mean i had fun anyway
so uh thank you for making it fun
and uh
yeah see you tomorrow
bye bye
i woke up uh the morning that i found
out to a
dm on instagram from somebody who wasn't
following me all it said was hey parker
i'm sorry to have to tell you this but
your friend michael died i was the first
person at the scene i was the first
person to call the cops i'm here if you
need to talk to me really really sorry
and i was just like yeah sure you know
just just send me proof along thinking
like okay this is where the joke falls
apart
and over the course of the next like
hour or so this guy started sending
proof that was
impossible
to verify
without this being a
a complete misunderstanding
or b it was true
the police had called and left a message
at 5 30 but because it came in as an
unknown caller i didn't see it really i
didn't pay attention
and um
i didn't find out till tuesday morning
uh probably like 11 in the morning
when
somebody was at the door the dog was
barking uncontrollably i opened it up
and there's two officers and it's like
oh
he crashed i i know he crashed we we
knew he hadn't come home that night
and then i looked at the officer's badge
and saw one of them said coroner
and that was the oh
it's weird knowing before the parents
knew because i knew before they
did and
when they're like
hey so you're probably wondering why
you're calling why why we want you to
call us and i was like
nope
i know why
it's a very it's an awful feeling
that nobody should have to go through on
october 11th 2021 michael kickstar
stockley passed away in a tragic and
unexpected car accident to say that his
friends family the siege community and
esports at large were inconsolable
would be an understatement
yeah okay cause we lost obviously a you
know community member uh like a
pro-league caster like the void will
never be filled for pro league for
casting ever
like it doesn't matter who's there just
it'll never be the same it won't and and
obviously you know we lost someone who
was you know a great like ambassador for
the game and and just a great all-around
guy and like a good friend too siege
loses
a
family member a friend
an advocate a
pillar a foundational pillar it's it's
really hard to put into words
exactly
what
you know what what we lost when kicks
passed away but um
yeah we lost someone really special
kickstar was in no uncertain terms a
part of the very soul of siege one of
the game's most iconic indispensable and
irreplaceable figures i mean i don't
know what rainbow six esports looks like
right now without kicks i don't
not even from like a casting perspective
but
his formulation of you know r6tms which
then was kind of like a precursor to fpl
and how that
brought like thousands to tens of
thousands of people to a competitive
level that people never seen before
strictly speaking you know that alone
was huge whether you were a seasoned vet
or an aspiring up-and-comer a nod of
approval from kickstar
meant everything in year one season one
we placed eighth place the literal last
place in north america
and then obviously you know i joined ctm
and won the six invitational he was like
he's like i gotta tell you he's like
good job he's like from eighth place to
first in the world he's like he's like
congrats so it was like it was it was
definitely like a really good memory and
it was like uh it was definitely like a
moment too because i still remember back
then
as well it was just like yeah everyone
thought that we were like terrible and
it's like you go from being like the
literal last place
to going to go in the first place and
having like kicks like
i guess uh you know like
validate that for you too like on top of
it like you know that's like where you
know it's like okay okay now it's now
it's official it was kind of like the
final part you know like he said
what he said is basically gospel kicks
his streams were like group therapy
sessions i would sit in them and i would
listen to them and i would you know he'd
sit back waiting for a cue and spend 20
minutes you know ruminating about his
life and talking about things that had
gone wrong and things that he wished
he'd been able to do in the future and
what he wanted to accomplish and then
you know the countless clips that were
shared after his passing about how
frank and honest he was about mental
health and suicide and depression i'm
not more
depressed than anybody else okay
like when i was when i was seriously
going through depression it wasn't
other people are experiencing the same
[ __ ] daily
it's an ongoing struggle for tons and
tons of people
and there's no reason for me to i got
you
everything's going to be okay in that
headspace why would i
so happy
to
to have heard that in his in his last
days
his whole response was i'm just feeling
good
i'm happy because that wasn't
michael when he first came to paul
he wasn't happy he didn't know who he
was there were months that felt
is he's just gonna open equipped he
pulled out of it that takes a lot of
strength and energy very
very proud to have been part of that
it goes without saying that a fixture
such as kicks
can never be replaced the man was a
legend a titan a foundational father a
constant never-ending force of comfort
and assurance in an e-sport that needed
it i feel like a lot of people in gaming
um you know suffer with their own
personal struggles and i know kix was
one of those people that just was able
to make you smile a lot of people turn
to him
for help and support and just honestly
just you know
just to give just uh i guess get away
from their own things they would just
pay attention and watch him and it would
just make things like a lot better
thanks thank you so much i love you bro
i watch you all the time i'm sorry i'm
fanboying i watch you all the time
through high school bro oh damn the
world of esports will never be the same
without kickstarter there's no replacing
someone like that someone who gave
everything they had to make the game
they loved the game in which they found
themselves a better place
but thankfully
there's also no forgetting
people say that we'll no longer have
michael and and yeah you will no longer
have anything new from him but we have
thousands and thousands of hours of of
him talking
to the camera on broadcasts
on social media but whenever you feel
like
you miss him just go watch this those
videos there's nothing else you need
and you will feel like he's here yes the
flame burned out but holy [ __ ] did it
shine bright while it was
you know lit up
definitely
and i'm i'm just really glad that i
could have been
a part of his life
um and i'm gonna miss him
you